lndia 210 cuenta con el cambio GMAT ago
until a El Nino effect au la condition
adult day optician de agua Julius any
other class and oh yes agua de Kalia
general I went to him from another gun
so actor Pino figured out how to make
water from air with the touch of a
button
Hector made a fortune as an engineer but
now works full-time on his fresh water
system what propelled you to think of
this project ran firm AI mija yeah Denis
Irwin Malcolm he need open your name
in batygin dr. mundo and the Latino here
[ __ ] cannot ignore Camilla doc a sudanese
and tanks Zoomer Dino the blue ship our
goofy guy Kalia yesterday Najia propane
mundo muy in total I saw a loan for
motto mexico para gimme hwy relic
Serizawa clement we're a la sauna sauna
to use this machine at home yes okay and
and your daughter uses this everyday
they complete my family when Aniyah ECC
at the annual there now yeah not mad
actor sees this technology having uses
far beyond his family his freshwater
machine feeds off humidity in the air it
pulls in water particles through a vent
and then basically forms a rain cloud
inside the machine a series of filters
purify the water collected and then
pristine h2o flows out of the faucet
[Music]
so I can drink it yeah yo baby well hell
I try anything it's no problem we
delicioso
right now one magic water machine cost
about 1,600 bucks but he wants to shrink
the price and its size to something like
a backpack as he perfects the design is
installed as machines in chillies dry
north look at Thomas Endora Tommy
Randall impacto unico Santillana
tecnología Yolo - si bueno Scipio
voila consecuencia yes impact Oh
sociological economic Oh el cata momento
para nosotros color assay auto pie
cemetery - buenos willtao actor distill
the idea for fresh water inside an
incubator funded by some of Santiago's
wealthiest people it's called the idea
factory for if for those into the whole
brevity thing they support tech with a
do-gooder bent politicians stop by to
schmooze kids get a chance to learn it's
not a factory designed to build the next
Google or Facebook if focuses on things
for Chile in South America and they've
got hyper local branches hidden in
unexpected corners of Santiago there are
tech incubators all over the world but
you won't find many in a neighborhood
like this if has another building here
that's been set up to inspire local
youngsters and give budding inventors a
helping hand
here in recoleta things are a bit more
lively than in palo alto and it suits
the place I showed up on a demo day when
kids from the neighborhood pour through
the gates to check out ifs gadgets there
was plenty of eye candy but nothing beat
this hello
robots it's like every other video
conferencing robot on a stick but this
one is basically leap
[Music]
that's so cool all of the gadgets come
from this man
rodrigo Quevedo he's something of a
local celebrity and has kanye west's
levels of passion for learning before so
when I'm in McGrath son
Kalani mentally handsome I almost album
but this year but one movie
don't say I give you a nose again anyone
else getting so lucky man let's see that
looks way more it look at him - again I
guess a more conciliatory Valley yeah
Rodrigo was an officer in the Chilean
army and then an engineer until he had a
revelation and became a robotics
entrepreneur his most inspired invention
is this wheelchair people can control it
by tilting their head or making a
gesture soon Roderigo hopes it'll move
by thought alone by reading impulses
from a brainwave monitor really
oh that Thomas en de da mucho más
pequeño yeah tell TMF my love Oceana
Rodriguez helpers were surprisingly
gentle as they gave me the power of
telekinesis but is in there is it Emma
that's how I turn it on three blinks see
it's like a genie foot know those Chris
oh my god
[Music]
that's crazy it's amazing it's fuzzy
[Music]
[Music]